[Applaudissements]
ryan bensetti qui nous a rejoint les
remercie d'être là avec un véhicule volé
laurent baffie je connais non mais c'est
quoi ça c'est quoi ce et bahia lego
batman qui seraient du coup j'ai fait un
lego baba non mais c'est notre article
comment c'est un cadeau non merci ou
ariane plein d'amour pour toi aussi mon
étiquette avec lauriane on adore ryan
buzzetti laurent baffie j'adore vous
connaissez ryan ou pas ce qu'il connaît
il connaît pas laurent il connaît et
reconnaît que des ryan c'est une immense
star bourgeois un cabas comédiens
danseurs réseau les bailleurs il a fait
vieux moi je fais de la télé avec
ardisson pas la même génération
c'est vrai mais c'est vraiment c'est la
star du moment ariane bensetti en tout
cas merci d'être là mont royal
on venait sur le conseil de classe de
jean michel noquet voulez mais avoue
j'aime bien